is it possible to be have a scientific
approach to the the prediction of the
future I mean we just went through this
with covet yeah what do we know about
modeling
well I mean what do we learn about
modeling with covet uh there's a lot of
lessons they didn't work at all
they worked poorly the models were
terrible the models were useless I don't
know if the models were useless or the
people interpreting the models and then
the centralized institutions that were
creating policy rapidly based on the
models and leveraging the models in
order to uh support their narratives
versus actually interpreting the error
bars and the models and all that kind of
stuff what you had with my view you had
with confidence you have these experts
on showing up and they claim to be
scientists and they had no testable
hypotheses whatsoever they had a bunch
of models they had a bunch of forecasts
and they had a bunch of theories and
they laid these out in front of policy
makers and policymakers freaked out and
panicked right and implemented a whole
bunch of like really like terrible
decisions that were still living with
the consequences of
um and there was never any empirical
Foundation to any of the models none of
them ever came true you had to push to
push back there were certainly Baptists
and Bootleggers in this in the context
of this pandemic but there's still a
usefulness to models no I I so not if
they're I mean not if they're reliably
wrong right then they're actually like
anti-useful right they're actually
damaging but what do you do with a pen
endemic what do you do with a were they
at with any kind of threat don't you
want to kind of have um
several models to play with as part of
the discussion of like what the hell do
we do here I mean do they work because
they're an expectation that they
actually like work that they have actual
predictive value
I mean as far as I can tell with covet
we just saw the policy makers just Psy
up themselves into believing that there
was I mean look the scientists the
scientists were at fault this is the
quote unquote scientists showed up so I
had some insight into this so there was
a remember the Imperial College models
out of London were the ones that were
like these are the gold standard models
yeah so a friend of mine runs a big
software company and he was like wow
this is like hope it's really scary and
he's like you know he contacted This
research and he's like you know do you
need some help you've been just building
this model on your own for 20 years do
you need some pictures like our coders
to basically restructure it so it can be
fully adapted for covet and the guy said
yes and sent over the code and my friend
said it was like the worst spaghetti
code he's ever seen that doesn't mean
it's not possible to construct a good
model of pandemic with the correct error
bars with a high number of parameters
that are continuously many times a day
updated as we get more data about a
pandemic I would like to believe when a
pandemic hits the world the best
computer scientist in the world the best
software Engineers respond aggressively
and as input take the data that we know
about the virus and it's an odd output
say here is here's what's happening in
terms of how quickly it's spreading what
that lead in terms of hospitalization
and deaths and all that kind of stuff
here's How likely how contagious it
likely is here's how deadly likely is
based on different conditions based on
different ages and demographics and all
that kind of stuff so here's the best
kinds of policy it feels like you could
have models
machine learning that like kind of they
don't perfectly predict the future but
they they help you do something because
there's pandemics that are like
uh
uh meh they don't really do much harm
and there's pandemics you can imagine
them they could do a huge amount of harm
like they can kill a lot of people so
you should probably have some kind of
data driven models that keep updating
that allow you to make decisions on base
like where how bad is this thing uh now
you can criticize
how horrible all that went with the
response to this pandemic but I just
feel like there might be some value to
models so to be useful at some point it
has to be predictive right so and so and
and so the easy thing for me to do is to
say obviously you're right obviously I
want to see that just as much as you do
because anything that makes it easier to
navigate through Society through a
wrenching you know risk like that is you
know that sounds great
um you know the the harder objection to
it is just simply you are trying to
model a complex dynamic system with
eight billion moving Parts like not
possible very tough can't be done
complex systems can't be done uh machine
learning says hold my beer but well it's
possible no I don't know I would like to
believe that it is yeah I will put it
this way I think where you and I would
agree is I think we would like we would
like that to be the case we are strongly
in favor of it I think we would also
agree that no such thing with respect to
covet or pandemics no such thing at
least neither you nor I think or where
I'm not aware of anything like that
today my main worry with the response to
the pandemic is that uh uh same as with
aliens is that even if such a thing
existed and it's possible it existed
the the the the policy makers we're not
paying attention like uh there was no
mechanism that allowed those kinds of
models to percolate up oh I think we
have the opposite problem during covet I
think the policy makers I think the
these these these people with basically
fake science had too much access to the
policy makers
well right and what but the policy
makers also wanted they had a narrative
in mind and they also wanted to use
whatever model that fit that narrative
to help them out so like it felt like
there was a lot of politics and not
enough science yeah although a big part
of what was happening a big reason we
got lockdowns for as long as we did was
because these scientists came in with
these like Doomsday scenarios that were
like just like completely off the hook
scientists and quotes that's not
quote-unquote it's not okay let's give
love so here's science that is the way
out science is a process of testing
hypotheses yeah modeling does not
involve testable hypotheses right like I
don't even know that my I actually don't
I didn't even know that modeling
actually qualifies with science
maybe that's a side conversation we
could have some time over a beer